[Musique]
c'est le plus grave problème de notre
temps disent les hommes de science et
les philosophes
la pollution des eaux met en cause la
santé voire la survie de l'espèce
humaine et c'est l'eau douce qui est en
voie de se polluer le plus
pour sensibiliser l'opinion et leur a
malheureusement fallu des catastrophes
comme l'empoisonnement du rhin de juin
dernier
il s'agissait là d'une pollution toxique
mais ce n'est qu'une des figures de la
pollution qui se présente à l'état
physique sous forme de solides ou
d'huile à l'état chimique en raison des
acides et autres substances verser dans
l'eau et l état biologique par
l'introduction dans les cours d'eau
d'algues de champignons et de virus
[Musique]
les efforts en élémentaire ne se font
plus normalement ce sont les poissons
qui souffre le plus dans des rivières
qui souvent sont des égouts à ciel
ouvert
les pêcheurs quant à eux en sont devenus
un peu scientifique dans la mesure où
ils ont voulu comprendre pourquoi
d'année en année il y avait toujours
moins de poissons
voici d'ailleurs ce que nous disait le
président de la fédération des pêcheurs
d'alsace il ya maintenant quelques mois
dans les eaux polluées forcément
la faune et la flore disparaît lentement
alors il ya plus de cycles microbien
s'il n'y a pas de fleurs et apathique
microbien forcément la poisse on n'a
plus rien à manger
larmes des pêcheurs face à ce fléau et
les simples élémentaire il remplace la
mort par la vie grâce à des alevinages
fréquents il arrive cependant que les
alva ne se développe pas comme il le
faudrait
les poissons change e mail au reste
toujours aussi dangereuses et invivable
comme nous le dit un naturaliste de
strasbourg monsieur car binaire le mal
est déjà plus profond pour le rein et
même ses affluents
en ce qui concerne les poissons et il y
avait un appauvrissement généralisé de
la faune piscicole la pollution n'est
pas seul en cause il y à d'autres
facteurs qui jouent la canalisation
elle-même la suppression des bras mort
enfin la pollution est un facteur
important surtout pour le real à la
disparition par exemple du saumon et de
des poissons de la même famille les
salmonidés la truite par exemple qui
était assez abondants dans le rhin
surtout vers l'amont encore il ya
quelques décades il y a encore 15 ans il
était fort agréable défendre le rhin à
la nage au fil de l'eau c'était
d'ailleurs pas très dangereux
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
le courant vous porte il n'est pas
profond actuellement on peut toujours
aller nager dans le rhin mais évidemment
on court des risques hygiénique certains
étant donné que le rein recèle une
quantité énorme de bactéries dont
certaines sont pathogènes malgré son
oxygénation élevé parce qu'il a une
capacité d'auto épuration faible c'est
la cas particulier qui est commun à tous
les fleuves très turbulent mais où la
flore est très réduit du fait même de
cette turbulence lorrain est pauvre en
végétaux supérieurs et les végétaux
supérieurs sont extrêmement importants
pour l'épuration des eaux
actuellement en france la moitié de la
pollution est d'origine directement
industrielle l'autre moitié est
provoquée par les villes et
collectivités locales
cette situation est illégale car depuis
1917 une loi interdit la pollution il
ses fils pendant d'un texte qui ne
résout rien au fond en 1964 ont donné
cependant au problème de la pollution
une dimension plus économique et plus
réaliste en effet supprimé en vingt ans
la pollution actuelle des cours d'eau en
france équivaut à dépenser la valeur de
quatre paquets de gauloises par habitant
et par an c'est sur la base de ces
constatations qu'ont été créés les
agences financières de bassin à metz le
directeur de l'agencé rameuses nous a
reçus
comment faites vous pour lutter contre
la pollution des eaux
financièrement et techniquement
bah c'est très simple pour lutter contre
la pollution des eaux il faut de
l'argent et pour avoir de l'argent
enlève des redevances sur les pollueurs
que tétouan dans cet argent est
réinvesti bas cet engin est
immédiatement investi il ya une partie
qui sert aux dépenses de fonctionnement
de l'agencé les études parce qu'avant de
l'étude de résoudre les problèmes il
faut les étudier et le reste
intégralement réinvestis sous forme d
aide pour la construction de la station
d'épuration des industriels ou des
collectivités locales
dans la pratique donc des études sont
menées avec la collaboration de sociétés
spécialisées dans l'épuration des eaux
ici dans une usine très polluantes de la
région de strasbourg il s'agit de
trouver la solution la meilleure et
surtout la moins chère
une usine d'épuration miniature a été
monté lorsque les résultats d'épuration
seront bons une station sera construite
à grande échelle un ingénieur de
l'agencé de bassin nous explique
d'ailleurs dans quelles conditions
alors ça sera évidemment ça va déboucher
sur une installation industrielle qui va
coûter cher enfin on peut déjà estimer
son prix entre un et deux millions de
nouveaux francs cette installation ne
peut pas être entièrement à la charge de
l'industriel race est le but des agences
de bassins d'aider à la réalisation ces
industries de ses installations en
encore en participant au financement et
nous pouvons déjà indiqué que pour cette
installation va celle qui sera réalisée
ici lagence apportera environ 50% du
prix servir de entre 500 mille et un
million c'est voler de nouveau franc
voilà quels sont actuellement les
solutions française mise en oeuvre le
rhin à lui seul le beigne les terres de
cinq pays européens à strasbourg au
début de l'année une charte de l'eau a
donc été signé par plusieurs pays
d'europe il s'agit là d'un premier pas
symbolique sur le chemin du respect de
notre capital dos au but il reste encore
beaucoup de travail aux hommes d'état
pour que des solutions économiques
efficaces soient approuvés
toute une économie tout un folklore une
gastronomie à pour départ nos cours
d'eau c'est un capital que l'on commence
à reconsidérer un peu tard peut-être
il aura fallu l'indignation des pêcheurs
des gastronomes et surtout celle des
savants pour alerter l'opinion trouver
une solution au problème de la pollution
c'est faire avant tout acte de
solidarité entre industriels et
collectivités locales pour financer des
équipements qui épure les eaux rejetées
par les usines et les villes cela au
niveau national et international il
faudra cependant faire vite sous peine
de risques graves
ces risques sont divers et multiples
naturaliste chi relèvera évidemment
d'abord une continuation une
accentuation de l'appauvrissement temps
de la flore et de la faune des eaux qui
peut aller si la pollution va en
empirant jusqu'à désertification
complète des cours d'eau des cas sont
déjà nombreux en europe où les cours
d'eau ne recèle plus aucun être vivant
supérieur à par des bactéries
très nombreuses ou même rien du tout
lorsqu'il ya une forte pollution toxique
ou c'est une alors vraiment le désert
biologique complet
dans un deuxième temps il ya surtout un
risque général pour l'environnement
humain étant donné le rôle que jouent
les au courant des nappes d'eau dans
dans notre vie de tous les jours sur le
plan de l'agrément de vie je relèverai
par exemple les possibilités les
multiples possibilités d'usagé des cours
d'eau pour les loisirs pour les sports
de plein air qui sont très fortement
altérée en cas de pollution et qui
comporte à l'heure aussi beaucoup de
risques sur le plan sanitaire sur le
plan mais même tout simplement sur le
plan de l'agrément des idées de ses
divers usages de l'eau
pour l'industrie l'eau doit devenir une
matière première aussi précieuse que
d'autres le gâchis doit être évitée
actuellement dans les villes la solution
au problème de la pollution des eaux est
une question de bonne volonté de
solidarité et de lucidité
il s'agit de savoir si l'on veut que
certaines formes de vie et disparus dans
quelques années par notre faute il
s'agit de savoir si l'on veut parler
dans quelques décades d'une friture
comme d'un plat préhistorique ou d'un
bain d'eau douce comme d'un plaisir
disparu
[Musique]